slowly turning Cold War gloves parallel
the slowly turning mindsets of the
Russian and American governments of the
mid-1980s oh oh boxing does not
typically create explosions also the
Cold War boxing glove explosion is more
than a little over-the-top
previously on rocky in 1982 at the end
of rocky three probably celebrated
Rocky's victory over clubber lang
by the time rocky 4 rolled around in
1985 you were hoping that this movie
would change the ending so that ba
Baracus could win the fight this time
almost seeing mr. T's balls by the way
we're still rehashing Rocky fuckin 3
right now hey asshole the last movie
ended like this and we all wonder what
the hell happened now you're gonna push
out and not show us the fight couldn't
you have at least started the movie here
wait written and directed by stallone
well that explains a lot actually
Rocky's lifestyle inadvertently costs
Mike Tyson all the dollars movie misses
out on his chance to start the entire
found-footage genre Jesus what movie am
i watching and here we are celebrating
the birthday of Polly who we saw in the
original rocky was a drunk and abusive
to his sister now getting robots to
serve and birthday cake
it's amazing what twelve years and three
sequels do to a character no kid they're
not several candles still burning nice
job God allow you so rocky is officially
not relatable now remember in the first
movie he was an underdog of no good bum
he was us now this movie starts out with
a Lamborghini a mansion a kid with his
own camcorder a robot servant and an
expensive necklace and we want this guy
to win because Russia is basically the
reason even if it looks like a snake to
worry cuz it won't budge this is exactly
what I told the girl who did not become
my college girlfriend will be naturally
transitions from a married couple in bed
to an ominous Sports Illustrated cover
photo because duh
oh wait two Lamborghinis and a robot
servant when Iranian cedar it rains
Lamborghinis okay sorry I'm making too
much noise waxing my second-favorite
luxury sports car I haven't Drago's
punch-out
as you can Argo averages eighteen
hundred and fifty Bob that's an average
after one punch now let's see what the
average is after two punches anyway we
don't know what his average is until he
throws several punches but whatever dude
is strong we get it all so we're now
going to be force-fed the belief that
Rakhi who is now much older and was
nearly destroyed by other boxers can
withstand a barrage of punches more than
twice the average of a normal fighter
Rakhi for UPS the NE for the number of
free screen transitions you can stomach
in a movie I mean what at this point in
your life is worth getting hurt for
dumbass reject from Skynet interrupts an
important conversation because 1985
that's why girl I don't like the way
Paulie called this robot my girl and
everyone seems comfortable with the fact
that Paulie bangs this thing regularly
rich people I gotta say I've already
forgotten what you were saying more
robot much like the audience rock in
creator spending most of their time
watching past highlights from the
previous films and without some some
challenge without some damn war to fight
in the war you may as well be danced out
for satire knee this article about Creed
and Drago is about the United Auto
Workers Union no wait it's about Central
American refugees also this stuff
happening in the u.s. is all taking
place in London zoom you know you've
been raped for like five years movie
characters and movie keep reminding me
how long Apollo has been out of the game
which is a huge tip-off that he's about
to die so thanks movie whoever's in
charge of this exhibition fight is a
total dick and doesn't even allow Drago
his own entrance they just lift him into
the arena already in the ring Drago is
getting a heaping helping of America
right now that'll teach him
movie has come to a full stop to
advertise its soundtrack why is Apollo
Creed ascending into the boxing arena in
front of a giant evil seat and go face
it was the mid-eighties so this blatant
product basement still only cost Hugo
Boss 27 dollars and 33 cents I mean
we're even going through the whole
roster of American cities in the song
this movie has more filler over 90
minutes than a Saturday Night Live
episode man for the first time ever West
against East professional sports that's
all kinds of untrue what kind of boxing
match takes place in a traditional stage
theater with only half the ring
surrounded by audience members first off
I just watched that movie last night it
was not what I was expecting
Drago clearly punches Apollo after the
bell but suffers no consequences couple
cigarettes Ivan Drago is definitely for
real
I mean he's destroying a guy who's been
retired from boxing for five years I'm
ready to call this guy a champ after one
round of a fight
very regrettable orders no and no
medical professionals were on site for
this fight leaving Apollo to die in the
arms of another boxer surrounded by
photographers ah yes the 1980s where
action films were almost always
predicated on getting revenge for a
friend brother or uncle dying Apollo
Creed's super popular former heavyweight
champ has a funeral attended by about a
dozen people rocky honors Apollo at his
funeral but can't be bothered to take
off his sunglasses this entire goddamn
article is about the 1985 World Series
between the Royals and the Cardinals
rocky gets home late at night but right
the hell is his wife's car that we just
saw her leaving the driveway
just gonna do what I gotta do how did
this decision get made without her
knowing anything about it it sounds like
rocky woke up told Adrian I'm not
fighting that dude and by afternoon they
called a press conference and he made a
decision to go to Russia on Christmas
but today goes dude not the thing to say
to your wife who was worried about you
dying in this fight the rocky really not
get a personalized plate that got the
whole word southpaw in there or is that
how his brain which has taken many hits
over the years thinks it's belt
angry at Russian boxer who killed my
friend driving montage cliche also hears
montage 1 don't worry there will be
plenty more this montage is nothing but
rocky thinking of rocky 1 through 4
footage it's a way to get the audience
to think yeah there was a point in time
I saw these movies and I remember all
that stuff
hooray for memory also rocky literally
just got home super late at night after
a tiring day he had one small
disagreement with his wife and then back
out on the roads also nearly 4 full
minutes of stupid memories that are a
thinly veiled attempt to make ton of
cash by letting this entire song run
during the film if I've told you what
Jesus did they stumble on actual AI back
in 1985 for this robot hello Rocky's
kids video camera doesn't even have a
color viewfinder I'm gonna have a wires
tied when I get back this may be the
most disturbing thing I've ever heard in
a movie leave say goodbye to my son seen
floods the right side of the shot with
an orgy of evidence that it's a boys
room from the BMX bike to the dyno robot
to the football the stuffed dinosaur the
Steelers pennant etc also what kind of
asshole parks his bike in his bedroom if
a big giant man wanted to beat me up I'd
be real scared
ladies and gentlemen child actors delay
the scene is shot and cut I am genuinely
questioning of Stallone and this kid
even shot their lines in the same room
would it be hilarious if somehow this
kid just super intimidated Stallone and
he refused to film with him so we ended
up with this tight cut conversation
rather slight by the way why the Paulie
need to even come on this trip four will
read that enamored with his character
this is a guy who hit his sister in
robots I was like retract this cuz
that's racist
hello TV not did they not discuss
everything in the world about this fight
when they were on the 16-hour flight to
Russia no room service I bet this is a
sentence so stupid it's not worth uh
turing let alone leaving in the final
cut of the film depressing vacation I'm
really beginning to think his character
wasn't high demand how the hell that
happened when he died part of me died
especially since I was screaming throw
the damn towel for ten seconds prior to
him dying while you did nothing but
let's forget that for now water under
the bridge I've literally forgotten
about it
no one will be seated during the
exciting guy looks through his
binoculars seen oh snap
here comes Montag number two folks only
11 minutes after the last one buckle in
it's a montage arrived this is the only
sports training montage in film history
to include the rescue of a horse from a
snowdrift rocky somehow knew the perfect
training regimen for this fight would
include good old-fashioned longer
activities also Rocky's training is so
low-tech and homey you'd swear this is a
political commercial he forgot the
narrator rocky goes out into nature and
saws wood well Bravo goes to his
expensive personal gym to lift weights
and use his computer's electronic champ
in 1985 also what would the
counter-attack I'd be on Drago side
rocky says he's down to earth but that
motherfucker owns two Lamborghinis a
mansion and a spot now who's a rich
asshole films editor really went
overboard with the training differences
in parallels knocking out a dude is the
same thing as chopping down a tree now
you know I'm with you no matter what no
matter what movie suggests Adrian was
wrong all along about this boxing match
and rocky was right which is the
opposite of what common sense tells me
I'm here two minutes after the last
montage montage number three hits you in
the head like you're clever Lange
looking for a rematch by the way
whatever happened to that guy did he
quit after Rocky beat him once when you
think about it this is really the sequel
to the earlier montage it's exact same
montage only with a few different
exercises it's the hangover 2 of
montages okay damn this guy is getting a
workout just saying nope ain't as if the
guy isn't villain enough yeah he's
taking steroids crumpling the picture
means he's ready oh maybe not did
Rockets call Drago's name during orgasm
months into his training rocky finally
realizes he can jog off road to escape
his Russian tail I would have subtracted
50 sins if somehow they found a way to
stick the Philadelphia Art Museum up
here discount real discount Gorbachev is
disco a bunch of American extras
pretending to be Russian boo and
American going through a fence and his
concentration seems to be like stop ya
know what do you think we are nerds
Rocky Sun is just loser enough to only
be able to invite bullies to his viewing
party gotta hand it to the Russians at
least a stage they're both boxing match
in and in the round style auditorium
unless they also there is clearly a
sniper in this audience currently zeroed
in on Drago's neck shenanigans in this
movie the fight is fairly even in real
life he'd had so much reach advantage
he'd likely never even get hit once I
guess we missed the part on the montages
were rocky chopped down trees with his
face so he could withstand these punches
rocky Balboa's and serious trouble well
he is fighting a few steps up from its
weight class and the Russian uses
steroids but whatever
I went to a boxing match and a WWE match
broke out hey man this guy lifted a nip
full of rocks during his training so it
prepared him for twenty-one hundred
pounds of force to the face and here's
the classic Rocky fight montage montage
number for getting the montage is 15
minutes of screen time if you subtract
them along with rock III rehash and
credits this movie would be like an hour
also a movie that is made up of 40%
boxing footage devolves into multi round
montage in the finale because apparently
you viewers don't actually want to see
boxing despite that being all you wanted
to see up till now you cheers now for
Rocky Balboa what might have had more
impact for me the viewer if I'd taken
that journey with the spectators instead
of you know watching a series of
montages that made no sense after
watching a series of training montages
that were totally unnecessary
one more you know I can maybe with a
stretch believe rocky lasted a couple of
rounds taking the hardest punches he has
ever taken in his life but the distance
edu seriously the Russians cheering for
Rocky is the most unbelievable thing
ever hey you took a couple hundred
punches we didn't think you could re row
I had no idea rocky chop down trees
during his training but this
conveniently John's with the movies
metaphor hmm maybe we should take down
that wall in Berlin after all well
Russia sure warmed a democracy in a
hurry both countries obviously should
have spent more time on boxing based
diplomacy instead of nuclear weapons
technology during this fight I seen a
lot of changing hey you remember in the
first rocky when it just ended after the
fight was over nope time to make a
speech about how we can all change I
think we can thank rocky for ending the
Cold War yeah do two guys showing each
other but I guess that's better than 20
million I don't know of a more serious
statement to deserve a lot more than
that one if I can change you can change
openly idealistic world view also this
speech paves the way for Steven Seagal's
on deadly ground speech
what an asshole I just want to say one
thing to make chin who should be old
sleeping Moscow is 8 hours ahead of
Philadelphia so when did they decide to
hold this fight at 9:00 a.m. so in the
end what did we learn
rocky fought this fight for revenge but
Drago was still alive and Apollo is
still dead and somehow the fight brought
the US and Soviet Union together which I
still can't believe I just saw so bring
on the McDonald's Russia you deserve it
mr. Gorbachev tear down this war
I can't hold my tongue these kids are my
grandchildren and you are raising them
wrong
they're terrible boys shut up chip well
go out on your ass the bad blood the
feeling street could be felt all over
this baby is abyss I was your age
television was called books and this is
a special book it was the book my father
used to read to me when I was sick and I
used to read it to your father child do
or do not there is no try
but something's always bad and for some
feelings never gain I'm not asking for
another chance I just wanna know there's
no easy way
there's no shortcut